let's bring you some breaking news from
Italy we have the latest figures they
issued daily figures about deaths in a
number of cases and the latest news is
that the coronavirus deaths have risen
by 683 in 24 hours lifting lifting the
total death toll to 7503 yesterday the
death toll rose by 743 so that is a drop
and previously yesterday on Monday and
Sunday there had been a drop from
Saturday's death toll of 793 in the
total number of cases now has risen to
74 thousand three hundred and eighty-six
from sixty nine thousand one hundred and
seventy six on Tuesday okay the United
Nations is appealing for two billion
dollars to support humanitarian efforts
worldwide to fight the corona virus
pandemic in an exclusive interview with
our diplomatic editor James BAE's
secretary-general and Tony Gutierrez
says it is in everybody's interests to
help the world's poorest nations
especially in areas of conflict well
this is exactly an appeal for that it is
a humanitarian appeal for those
countries in conflict for those fragile
states for refugee camps it's all
displacement camps that have dramatic
humanitarian needs that need to go on
being met but on top of that have now
the threat of kovat 19 and we need to do
everything to prevent the disease to
come to those areas to the extent
possible and at the same time in those
areas you have people sometimes in slums
of big cities or in camps in which it's
very difficult to have isolation there
is no water in the households sometimes
no soap healthcare facilities are
extremely rudimentary so we need to
boost the response capacity in those
areas that's why we have asked and we
mobilize all UN agencies the Red Cross
Red Crescent Movement a large number of
NGOs we mobilized all to work together
and with those funds with those two
billion dollars to make sure that we are
able to have a strong push for
prevention in those vulnerable areas and
at the same time too
the equipment that is required the
ventilators tests suits for the the
staff to allow for contact with people
impacted you've called for a global
ceasefire in conflict zones but let me
give you a couple of examples in recent
weeks things have been going in the
opposite direction in some of those
conflicts let me ask you how worried you
are about the increase in hostilities in
Yemen well I am even if one of the most
important movements in Yemen has
declared that they would accept this is
fire or that the appeal of ceasefire we
have other armed movements in other
parts of the world saying that they
would be ready to abide by it all our
special representatives and their voice
everywhere in the world are pushing to
make sure that this appeal is translated
in diplomatic action bringing together
the parties to the conflict for the
ceasefire to become a reality we have
had initiatives in Syria in Yemen in
Libyan very in many other parts of the
world and I hope that this appeal will
be heard and that people will understand
that there is only one Wars
that is necessary today it's a war
against the virus you mentioned Libya
there there was already supposed to be a
humanitarian pause in Libya but one side
has not been respecting it general
Haftar in recent weeks seems too
intensified his campaign what's your
message to him it's necessary to stop
and I believe that in the last few days
there was a clear decrease in
hostilities even if even the day before
yesterday there was a very meaningful
attack but this is the moment to stop
all military action this is the moment
to concentrate on fighting covet 19
we're already seeing curb it 19 cases in
Gaza you've been there you know it's one
of the most crowded places on earth how
are you supposed to self isolate if
you're someone living in a place like
Gaza well it is extremely difficult but
the same applies to the slums of big
cities in different parts of the
developing world two refugee camps it is
much more difficult and that is the
reason why we massively need support for
those areas and we massive need to
increase the capacity to respond and the
health services
that are so weak in those areas need to
be very quickly boosted